[Music]
that is four-time grammy award winner
keith urban bringing keith urban live
las vegas to caesars palace this weekend
while he was warming up today he
welcomed 30 guitar students from the las
vegas academy to join him can you
imagine it'd be incredible
photo journalist eric youngblo was there
to capture the jam session with our
local musicians
so
long story short i got to play with
keith urban which is awesome because i
didn't expect that at all
just i came up with a little riff and
sure enough i got to go up there and
play it and i was like mr urban mr urban
please let me go up there let me play
sure enough i got to and honestly it's a
dream come true to play with hall of
famer
[Music]
you don't get opportunities to
come and feel what it's like to be on a
real stage and a real venue and get some
advice i mean i wished i had those
opportunities
when i was in that same situation so
it's just being able to
you know give back something like that i
get to
learn a bit about the questions you know
like they're really good questions about
balancing things and uh it's great
because the the same things i've
struggled with and still do you know
it's i'm not alone listening to uh
keith urban's advice on everything
from
how you make it to how you started out
and where you are now so
yeah it's just a wonderful experience